he just starts going crazy because
apparently he'd be really nervous
backstage and you know and then he go
out and just destroy
isn't that crazy with so in that town it
has like anxiety issues or or you know
the nervous like what you never said
that's why I David let him and stop
doing Stan hey did the nerves of it cuz
really every night hated do it wasn't no
but but you know then I'd be whitey
baseball time yeah why my reasons why I
have my reasons I got REI the boy oh I
don't like he passed on you know I did a
show I did send up on a show don't think
he's funny was never a comic you don't
is do to be this Mars guild host I'm
gonna be in a host good watch this what
will the greatest not not not close to
he's just there for a long time not
close to the Conan O'Brien oh look
what's that guy but after that got a go
smart snarky snarky good you know you do
it long enough you're gonna be okay but
now I got nothing for David he wasn't a
good comic how about that wasn't that's
a fact he was a he was a weatherman yeah
and then he became a comic uh I tried to
be kind of a writer well you know why he
stopped doing comedy Jay Leno
he saw Jay Leno's like how good he was
and he was like a wordsmith and his
grind means it go I'm not I'm not gonna
do that like I can't compete with that
how the hell do you get the show then
and then crazy how do you live in a time
right place right time good you know
what that good yeah not bad probably
pretty smart hard work who's definitely
good
he was really good yeah I loved watching
he caught a sight Geist he was I
remember when he became famous and and I
remember when he started and why people
liked it it was a it was a time
yeah when somehow that fit in he was so
it was like jadianna what do you think
Jay Leno's funny for those hoes like
that's what you know but I like but do
you think Carson's funny
Carson was very good at what he did
right he was good
so he was so Carson would dude Carson's
timing was was so available yeah I think
Kyle I think Conan's the ball I love
Kimmel - I like Kimmel Diana
I love camels out strike Fallon sounds
good
I like Kimmel I like and I like her oh
no honking now when they stood up the
big boy James Gordon is great - don't
know I don't see me at the same time
they do like the car karaoke head do
skits mmm I love it he's killing it
watching those shows though no one's
watching a minute more like you're gonna
get more eyeballs on this yeah I went on
100% Alan or so it's not the same like I
I don't want to know hate but burning
your material on those shows aren't like
what they used to did you ever do I just
a night show and I'm telling you right
now man I did it with Jay Leno and what
year man this is 15 years ago yeah so
2004 and I got a I killed it and I
didn't know how many people watched it
because I was still working at Nordstrom
Rack I was a shoe salesman so they would
you know you bring the right foot to me
and I go get your left foot in the back
yeah and and yeah that one and I'm
wearing a patent leather Air Force Ones
and uh and every single customer was
like dude you were so funny on this
Tonight Show
that's no lie that's so and then I got a
commercial deal from this set ever I got
a commercial deal from this set I got I
went on this major tour for a cell phone
company they were paying me like 3,000 a
gig I mean all from this set change my
life changed my life I was working at
Nordstrom Rack and borders books at this
time I was broke and I was little I was
able to quit my job
Wow job that once because of that
separate night for minutes it I did
Letterman in 1999
look at those Air Force a guy named
Wayne cook as part of a new Cano a leaky
jeans those yeah well you were you
nervous for the nose was in the bag oh
you know I want to cry backstage -
because Letterman passed on this set he
we sent it to him twice and he passed he
said it was your as well
your physical he hated this yeah he said
I was too physical or whoever was the
Booker and then Ross and Bob saw me do
this set at new faces at Jasper laughs
and they say
say that set we want to put you on the
best night so we're gonna find like the
best landing Morissette and Joaquin
Phoenix
yeah and that was and I got to stand I
remember I remember you back then
because we knew each other and you know
you were killing back then like you
would get up on at the Laugh Factory and
destroy rooms so it's like yeah and then
Letterman was like well what comes not a
lot left on this book a lot of times
it's not it's not it's but I'll say no
have a guy yeah
they have a guy but also a lot of times
it is there was a thing yeah well he did
I that's what they said can I just say
this is Jay he didn't like I know the
Booker's I know knew his book was pretty
well and they're awesome but they were
very very aware of what he liked very
very and to get a style they were very
tuned so they were very worried if
involved that they'd go to Jay Leno no
they did a great job Joe but before we
go on about Brian's past and you know
his issue with David Letterman this is
also a guy who doesn't think Brad Pitt's
very down Oh see I never said that and
Tom hey I never said you did do that I
never said they're not did he say that I
said they don't do anything
I've never gone to a movie for those
guys there are other actors I like you
said you ain't you never went to a movie
with Tom Hanks no never on Hanks on
what's posters never made you want to
buy a ticket Tom Hanks is awesome but
that's not why I would go to the movie
necessarily for whatever reason it's
like people like the police and the cars
the great bands never never really spoke
Brad Pitt Brad Pitt is a movie star
right he's a movie star it's just it's
just a different thing and III think
he's awesome in certain I loved him and
once upon a time in Hollywood I loved
him in heaven and in seven he was great
made him a star I loved him I know I
cried club he was awesome so certain
roles he's really awesome you know
anything with his shirt off yes yeah he
was great in Thalmann Louise I'm not
saying that he's a success not an
accident
it's just I'm what I'm saying is that
there are other actors as far as just
acting who can who be when characters
what do you say about him though what do
you say about rapid I don't go Brian
Brian shut the [ __ ] up there sir what is
it it's okay sir what do you what did
Brian say about Brad he essentially said
that he never went to a movie
specifically because those men were in
the film and then he started to double
down and said you know what I don't
think he's that good yeah dude you don't
that's what you said you have to face
that man that's exactly just won an
Oscar yeah you don't say something like
that right now
well what I say though after I saw Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood you took it
back
yeah sorry take it back right now let me
say I'm sorry that I said he's sorry is
not that he's not that good he's a
[ __ ] movie star yeah and he has magic
yeah charisma
oh you chase all bus and I'm telling him
and checks all boxes I'm telling you man
whatever you know what I thought was
lost him about once upon a time in
Hollywood is his ability to be great in
silence like his timing is impeccable
of course I just Pat in the past there
are other people that I I think are
better yes right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]